why do politicians want the FDA to crack
down on this energy drink
this is Prime energy a new caffeinated
drink created by social media celebrity
Logan Paul it contains 200 milligrams of
caffeine twice as much as a can of Red
Bull making it a target of Democratic
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
he's demanding that the FDA investigate
the beverage company for supposedly
targeting kids even though cans of Prime
energy have warning labels that explain
it's not recommended for anyone under
the age of 18. everybody needs to chill
out I mean compare Prime energy to
Coffee a Starbucks mini coffee has about
400 milligrams of caffeine which is
twice as much as a can of Prime energy
but nobody's losing their minds about
teens drinking too much Starbucks and
that's because the freak out over Prime
energy is actually just a new
permutation of the broader Panic about
social media busy bodies are desperate
to find any evidence that kids scrolling
through Instagram and Tick Tock are
negatively impacted even though it's
none of the government's business so
hands-off are Prime energy in fact I
think I'll have another